so let me start off by saying that this
is kind of a humble brag kind of kind of
like pat myself on the back story but I
can't help it because it pretty much
sums up my entire pieces of Avenue
business in a in a jab jab jab right
hook lay paid forward Thank You economy
way I was just coming down the street
and it's a busy street I was in cabinet
three blocks away from what I need to go
to for my next meeting
and I noticed this girl kind of sitting
outside looking for a cabin I was at a
red light and I said you know what let
me just jump out of here because she
won't be able to get a cab so he did and
that was nice and I said hey come over
and on the way over she's like oh like
but you're gary mitrik I'm such a huge
fan which I also thought was one because
it just wraps it all up for me which is
this I did something nice first paid
forward and in return I got a nice
moment got my ego kind of like built up
because I got bad in return just the way
the world works my friends I don't
understand how people don't realize
again